They're going to hate what I found today. Your loss is now even
more inevitable. Now I wait, winky face.
>> You're shaming me. And to imply.
>> Thank god Shamoo made this video. Stop looking for women
who literally take testosterone to be fitness influencers and
just admit you're gay. Wait, am I allowed to get offended when
people call people schizos because I have schizophrenia? This
is my one kind of qualm with Shamoo and some other people is
he's [__] Speechless.
He's literally
Oh, dude, Techtone's channel is really What the [__]
Bro, Techtone's channel is falling apart. Guys, if you don't
remember the Techtone stuff, Shamoo dropped the first two videos
that were basically like I feel like put Techtone under a lot
of pressure. He was freaking out about Um he he basically told
Shamoo, he told everybody that he was going to have
donating evidence that would prove he didn't do anything with
Pink Pinkchu. He didn't have that. Okay, court case went
I mean, I I don't really have to walk you guys through it too
much. We know how stuff went. And now this is Shamoo's, you know,
final video of the
Going over the court case and and what came out of it. >> Shibs,
since then the judge ruled in civil court that based on evidence
and testimony presented that Techtone likely raped A FAMILIAL
OBLIGATED RAPIST. >> stalked I'm stalking you. >> and
was a self-admitted woofy doofy >> I'm schizophrenic and
I have a gun. I'm a very dangerous man. If you are unaware and
want to know more on the timeline, Is he suing him civilly? Nope.
I don't know why she would sue him civilly. Like that would maybe
be something you do if you want money.
But I think she makes like more money than him. So, that's Yeah,
she makes more money. I don't know what the >> history,
you should have checked out my first video on him. However, briefly
in February of 2024, Techtone's ex-wife Reem was going to come
out with SA allegations against him. Lawsuits and court fair
within locked these allegations under an NDA. However, later
Teckton's ex-girlfriend Pink Shew would also make allegations
came public. These allegations Pink made would ignite a long
battle between the two, which would end up in civil court where
a judge found that there were reasonable grounds to believe that
Teckton committed essay and stalking. Pink Shew would file for
a protection order on August 21st of 2025, just 1 month after
my second video, and it wasn't until January 23rd of 2026 that
a trial would take place with everything on the line. They go
Dude, do you want to know how easy it is to manipulate things
on the internet? I'm pretty sure this is my screenshot that I
basically like this this text like cuts off between pages. That's
all. >> found that there were reasonable grounds to believe
that Teckton committed essay and stalking. Pink Shew would file
for a protection order on August 21st of 2025, just 1 month after
my second video, and it wasn't until January 23rd 2026 that a
trial would take place with everything on the line. They go after
my family, and they call me a generational
in front of 1.2 million people.
the funny thing about Teckton, as I always have to point out,
is that he blames Pink Shew for other totally unhinged people
like saying [__] about him, right?
He blames her, and it's like, dude, you should blame the other
people. You should blame the other people who don't care. But,
there's like you can't focus there? You can't like focus your
hate on somebody? And so, people like Teckton, like
Miz does this a little bit, obviously.
Destiny. There are people It's like They're they're being maligned
by like um a decentralized thing, and so, they just pick somebody
cuz they need something to focus on and hate and be mad at. And
so, they just pick something even if it doesn't really make sense.
I will just be your paper. >> Very funny.
>> Reuben Reuben donated $3.
Teckton has what Trump would consider bad genes.
Thank you so much, Reuben Reuben. Appreciate it, man. It's been
a wild ride, because I'm telling you, when when I get exonerated,
I'm going nuclear. I did everything for you. I helped you with
everything. I fixed everything for you. I was there for you like
nobody else was there for you in your whole life. I fantasize
about getting the report that says By the way, it would be so
much harder to make this video and make Techtone look like a
total psycho if he wasn't constantly saying he was one going
to exonerate himself and two that he was going to go nuclear
on her or attack her back after he had exonerated himself, right?
Like all he had to do was go this isn't true. I think this person's
like struggling. I'm going to ignore this.
Right? That's all you had to do.
And then go to court or do whatever you have to do in the background,
but like for public statements, there was just no reason to go
as hard as he did. Your case has been indefinitely suspended.
They call him a generational
Yes. Be sure to like the video and leave a comment as it helps
with the algorithm. If you want to support, you can do so with
the I'm getting What is that Asmongold's clip [__]
right there? Your case has been indefinitely suspended. They
call him a generational
Yes. Be sure to like the video and leave a comment as it helps
with the algorithm. If you want to support, you can do so with
the links on screen now. This video will look to illustrate why
Techtone lost his case in such a spectacular fashion. By considering
testimony, court and medical records, along with greater contextual
evidence from what Techtone has said on his streams, it should
become quite clear why Techtone lost his case. Beyond the courtroom,
we will also look at how Techtone has leveraged his relationships
with other online creators to defend him, issue talking points,
and in some cases directly attack Pink who had just been given
a 10-year protection order against him. Techtone could be seen
as a use case for what not to do when accused of SA. In court,
Pink had medical records of a lip injury sustained during the
alleged assault. So what does Techtone do? Talks about and confirms
the injury on stream. You know what you can't do to women who
have lip filler? YOU CAN'T HER MOUTH.
BECAUSE IT'LL RUPTURE THE [__] LIP FILLER. More on
this later. Techtone was represented by Jeffrey Perrier who has
experience in cases involving essay and abuse. Oh, does he going
to do is he going to do the whole Jeffrey Perrier testimonial?
This testimonial is so goofy and it's so funny when you read
it and you're like, oh, this is what TeKTONE read and then he
was like, oh, THIS IS THE GUY FOR ME. >> ALLEGATIONS. On
his front page, the one case that is listed in detail is a summary
of a man he represented who is accused of a his stepdaughter.
After Mr. Perrier represented him, he was found not guilty. Pink
was represented by Michelle L. Lock who specializes in divorce,
custody, and protective order applications. In TeKTONE's lawyer's
opening statement in just the second paragraph, it contradicts
what TeKTONE has lied to his audience in the past about. It states,
quote, "It's true that the applicant or Pink never paid rent."
End quote. However, during TeKTONE's original response to these
allegations, he claimed the exact opposite. >> You say
that I would say, "Do your job. You don't pay rent." This is
factually untrue. Here is you paying rent, not one time, but
multiple times.
That is I wonder, did we I don't know if we got an answer on
this. Which of these rent payments was actually for bots?
Do we know? is you paying rent. >> He has also claimed
the opposite of this as well. It's Pink's responsibility. The
reality is that she's in my house role playing as a goth Hooters
order orderer waitress. And honestly, it's really annoying because
the reality is she doesn't pay rent. The reality is she doesn't
pay rent. What TeKTONE was trying to slight of hand here is that
Pink originally was not paying rent. Allegedly, when TeKTONE
made it Pink's job to perform oral acts on him in lieu of paying
rent, she asserted that she wanted to pay rent. So, TeKTONE >> You
go to your girlfriend you're like, "I want you to suck my and
she's like, I'd rather pay you thousands of dollars than do that.
Fantastic relationship. Fanta- awesome relationship right there.
That's That's super cool.
TeKTONE's lawyer's opening statement, totally contradicting his
own public response to essay allegations, is a good sign as to
how this trial would go. Pink would take the stand and flush
out some of the allegations being made and the start of their
relationship. Quote, he told me he said, I could change your
life. I'm in OTK. I have connections. You should just move in
with me. You won't have to pay rent and I will help you and you
can try to help me. Here's some vitamins and was like, I'll change
your life and we'll get you better and kept telling me that he's
going to change my career. In regards to OTK, the org Tectone
was a part of, she stated, they have pretty much control in Austin
to make and break your career. Whether you get invited to collaborations
or get sponsorships. They also have control and the owners own
one of the largest management companies that I was also a part
of at the time or he got me into because that was another promise
he said he could do. According to Pink, originally she was doing
graphic design and thumbnails for Tectone to compensate for paying
rent but this would become warped over time. Quote, I just would
help him with some thumbnails. So in my assumption, it would
just be helping him because I do graphic design and media. So
I like make his thumbnails and edited some things for him. It
went from make this thumbnail for me to he kept telling me to
suck his And at the time, he would tell me, do your job, you
don't pay rent. And those are the words that I clearly remember.
Okay, and how soon after you moved in did those issues begin?
I believe it was the end of February, I started paying rent.
I gave him $1,000. I said, I didn't like that dynamic. It made
me feel disgusting. What Pink Chue alleges in her testimony paints
Tectone as a very manipulative person. Whenever [clears throat]
I had complaints about how he was treating me or anything, he
said my because I'm on my version of reality is not like normal
people and that he would have to explain to me what was really
going on. And you all had a journal, is that right? I kind of
just started one. He had me write a list of things he said that
were wrong with me that he said I needed to give my
Dude, it's The weird thing is is he like doesn't dispute almost
any of this. That's what makes it like so weird is you should
go up and when you're doing cross, like you should basically
you should have some story for how this goes on your end, right?
I feel like it's so weird to just not have any counter narrative,
any counter story here, nothing. It's just like he's let all
of this stuff go. By the way, nothing wrong with helping your
partner get a list of things that they want to do for like their
psychiatrist, but you better not have any like final say in that
better not be things wrong with them. Maybe it could be like
a little thing you write that's like your idea of what the problem
is, but you should be you should be trying to help them come
up with things they think needs to change.
It's not you being like, "Hey, you're not sending them to the
vet, okay?" The psychiatrist is not the vet for your girlfriend.
Can we can we not?
I don't know. I It's just goofy, man. And then he later graded
me on the things he thinks I need to work on. It's really fun
about this camera. I knew it would work great, right? But Pink
is stupid and she has this thing called social anxiety. And what
did he say that you needed to go see a psychiatrist for? That
my memory recollection was incorrect. I believe I wrote it in
my journal. I can't remember by specific. Cuz I I can't tell
you how many times I go into something with good faith, the other
person doesn't have proper memory recollection, gets confused
about what they're doing, the stress of the situation gets to
them, and then they just they say all this is not the word, but
they'll say things like, "Oh, you gaslighted me. You manipulated
me. You're straw manning me." He said I was immature, that my
memory Why do I just feel like any of the any of that language
like comes up in Maybe gaslighting could be a thing in a relationship,
but like
you're straw manning me. I If I had a relationship argument where
somebody said, "You're straw manning me," or I had to say that
to my partner, I just feel like you could just end the
That's not how normal people talk. There's something very wrong
going on. You're straw manning me. Memory recollection was incorrect,
that my phrasing, you know, he would [clears throat] say things
and then I would phrase it incorrectly, that I lacked communication
skills, that I was depressed and dooming a lot, that I wasn't
a positive person, I didn't take accountability, I was not independent
enough, I was paranoid, and I had no emotional control. He quick
continued by claiming Tectone would have her write a list on
paper of what she needed to tell her doctors during her online
appointments. And then I pull out the whiteboard. Another insane
thing we got out of this trial was that Tectone, when he had
a disagreement with Pink or when he wanted to explain why her
memory recollection of events was incorrect, would actually sit
Pink down at a whiteboard and John Madden game play why she can't
remember events clearly Uh
or why he's correct. This is a top Bronson classic right here.
Top Bronson, you did this, right? I believe.
Is you? Put this together real fast? correct on something they
disagree about. >> Good times. >> says to Tectone,
you actually would sit her down with a whiteboard and go over
everything to convince her she was wrong, right? Uh I'm failing
to see how these two connect, but I don't understand what do
you in what regard? We have talked with a whiteboard before.
Oh, if we were to have an argument, then we weren't seeing eye
to eye. Visual aid really helped her as well as her to me. This
was another very frequent commonality, where I would have to
sit down with her and I would tell you exactly what I did. I
would take her, I would run the shower in the bathroom because
it would be nice background noise because I know people get overwhelmed
from noises. So, I would put that on to calm her. I would sit
her on the floor, and we would sit there for hours as I would
bring out the coloring board, and I would draw out the issues
that you were experiencing, and I would help you through each
and every single one of your problems. And I did this from start
to finish.
Every time you had an issue. And do you know what coercive control
is? Like that could be something that's fine. I'm not going to
I'm not going to immediately say like obviously there's something
bad happening there.
Uh I don't know. I'm trying to think of like a way I could see
it being fine. It's probably not good that
he's saying like I'm not You can't How do I put this? I think
trying to totally destroy someone else's like reality is obviously
bad.
I'm trying to think of like he probably thinks he's helping.
I just he just doesn't have the tools. Does not have the tools
to help at all. Like Yeah, yeah, yeah. Basically, I could see
some of this being good.
But unfortunately for Tectone, I don't think he has any idea
where to stop and stop like like he's not I don't I don't fully
believe that he's doing it for her good. For for like just for
her sake, right? I I just don't see it. I don't know. We'll see
more. I think I would maybe believe that he was doing it more
for her sake if he wasn't explaining to his chat 3 months after
she accused him like exactly every dynamic of the relationship.
Like this is something that should stay private in my opinion.
He shouldn't be talking about this at all. The fact that he's
trying to use it like weaponize it to say I actually cared about
her. Look at how much Look at how much I cared about her. Here's
like a whole story about how I spent hours with a whiteboard
trying to explain to her how she was
I It leans me in a direction for sure. >> Yes. And you
told her that she had memory problems, right? >> I believe
we have had discussions on her memory not being, you know, as
sharp as a tack. Sure, I'm sure we've had conversations about
memories. Besides game planning like John Madden with Pink on
how she couldn't remember anything, Tectone was also guiding
her as to what medication she should be taking. Pink's lawyer
asked Tectone, "Did you tell her what things to tell her therapist
to get prescribed certain medications?" I definitely tried to
help her understand you know, try to help her make sense of what's
going on in her head. You know, she wanted to tell me this is
kind of happening to me and I'd say, "Well, maybe it's this."
I definitely tried to help her in her journey to therapy and
medication. Pink's lawyer paints this picture to the court this
controlling guy using whiteboards for hours to explain to his
girlfriend why she can't remember anything correctly, what pill
she should be on, and what to tell doctors to get sick. Oh, that
was the one that was [__] Is he has no experience,
he's literally never talked to a mental health professional and
he was saying, "You need to get on this stuff." That was [__]
okay? >> pills. Directly after this, Pink's lawyer passes
the witness and Tectone's rep has nothing to say or add on to
any of this. My takeaway, and I'm not a lawyer obviously, but
Tekton's team must think that getting any further clarity on
these topics will only make their client look worse. Why else
wouldn't there be any pushback or further questioning? You really
have to admire how poorly Tekton has handled this situation,
which would inevitably make him look no idea what what you've
unleashed. You have no idea what you've >> awful in court.
At one point, Pink filed a cease and desist against him. Even
after going to the police, he still would not stop harassing
me, and I had an attorney send him a cease and desist telling
him I had gone to the police and he needs to leave me alone.
Did that stop him? No. In fact, he went public and laughed about
it, said, "She sent me a cease and desist for defaming her, but
I'm going to keep defaming her." >> I got to send I got
to send the cease and desist about 3 months ago saying I need
to stop defaming my ex and then I continue saying the exact same
[__] that I've been saying. The only thing that I
got for Pink was a cease and desist because Pink sent me a cease
and desist to stop defaming her 8 months ago, and I've been going
live and saying the same [__] that I've been saying
for 8 months. That's okay.
More and more, it gets worse every day for everybody else besides
me. She even has a cease Dude, why? Why Why couldn't this guy
just shut the [__] up? That's the other thing about
all of his stories where he's saying like he's, you know, doing
all this work for her. It's like, dude, I just don't believe
that when you spend stream after stream after stream denigrating
this person. I don't believe it. I don't.
cease and desist on me?
Right? She sent me a cease and desist.
And I've never stopped talking a single all women with big tits.
She bought those, TOO. SO, LIKE, THEY'RE JUST PLASTIC, BROTHER.
LIKE, WHAT? LIKE, A BUSINESS IS A 30-YEAR-OLD
WOMAN SAYING THIS [__] I HAD TO [__]
TAKE CARE OF HER ASS AFTER SURGERY. ALL BECAUSE the [__]
couldn't just say I love that he's having this rant with a dance
tweet on the stream. You love to see it. Dan getting associated
with just the best people over time. These are the best people
the
I don't know why he does it. I don't know. I don't know, man.
I had TO TAKE CARE OF HER ASS AFTER SURGERY ALL BECAUSE THE [__]
couldn't just say things didn't work out. Uh she got the word
Dan TechTone
You love to see it. >> Guys guys to give you even more
context, I'm currently on a cease and desist by her. TechTone
would make so many sub tweets and threats towards Pink. >> What are
the odds TechTone has watched this video? Roughly 100%. TechTone
watches all videos about him. He constantly Googles himself.
He constantly searches himself on YouTube. He was in the Ryal's
comments. He was in Preem's comments. He was in Chud's comments.
He was in
Bazooka's comments. He was in FoodShop's comments. He was everywhere.
He I think he made a video where he talked about FoodShop's being
like a disgusting golem-like creature that was covering his content.
Right? He watches all of it. She 100% >> an archive and
list of these occurrences which is almost 200 pages long. Pink's
lawyer asked, "And what kind of threats was he making online?"
"I have a timeline of everything, but it was mainly I'm going
to sue you. He's also made threats that he's going to ruin me.
That TechTone would make so many sub tweets and threats towards
Pink that she put together an archive and list of these occurrences
which is almost 200 pages long. Pink's lawyer asked, "And what
kind of threats was he making online?" "I have a timeline of
everything, but it was mainly I'm going to sue you. He's also
made threats that he's going to ruin me. That everybody was going
to know the truth. That he was coming after me. That also that
there were explicit materials that he shared with multiple people
and that he will post them online if I don't retract statements.
And it's just
Oh, also there there were explicit material that he shared with
multiple
Dude, I would say I want to see the evidence of this this claim
right here. I assume it got submitted to the court. But like
if he actually sent these texts, that's he's [__]
at that point, no? It's It is almost 200 pages of it. And don't
worry, guys. I got something cooking for And man, Pink, you are
going to love that. And now you've built your entire image on
lies. And do you know what's going to happen when those lies
crumble,
You lose everything because you're a
And that's what's going to happen. Why y'all think Pink don't
talk about me no more? CUZ SHE KNOWS
CUZ SHE KNOWS
YEP. All she'll do is pin old tweets. She won't tweet anything
new cuz she knows she's
Yep. Won't say which is weird.
I forget about what a psycho this guy is
This is like the worst part to me was he would just like sit
on his stream and talk about how he was going to like how badly
he was going to hurt her once she, I guess,
I don't know.
I don't even know. He was just talking about how at some point
in the future he was going to [__] her life up. All
the time. Because before she had all this to talk about, but
man, Pink, if only you knew the [__] that I knew.
But don't worry. You'll find out. And what's crazy is, Pink,
and I'mma let you know, I would still forgive you if you apologized
publicly, of course. That's what's crazy. But you won't. And
it's going to be great to see what happens. YOU HAD TO SAY, "NO!
HE DID ALL THAT [__] no I didn't. Shut the up. Cuz
your ass always got to cry about They GOING TO SAY, "WELL,
AH, MY FAMILY. HE bombed my house. He set fire to a
And he hit me." It's like, "BITCH, JUST [__] SHUT
UP." Even after Pink filed a protection order in August 2025,
Tekton was still making threats on his Twitter. They are going
to hate what I found today. Your loss is now even more inevitable.
Now I wait, winkie face.
>> How do you you tweet this? Okay, by the way, this is
totally psychotic.
With the like dismembered the
Yeah, the beheaded picture here. Totally psychotic. But how do
you read this and you're like, I'm so cool on stream after tweeting
it? Attached to this tweet were decapitated heads of an anime.
Okay, and when you see these messages that he posts like this,
how did you interpret them? Like how did it make you feel? Like
he's coming after me. >> So crazy. Has he made threats
about going nuclear when the legal situation between you and
he ends? Yes, I believe it was at the time he was showing his
guns and things. And pretty much all of my homies and myself
included just like
because I'm telling you, when when I get exonerated,
I'm going nuclear.
I'm just being straight up. I am counting the days, bro. I fantasize.
Okay, and in fact, he's indicated on social media that he's schizophrenic
and is strapping, referring to weapons. Is that correct? Yes.
Dead people can talk. That's what people will learn very soon.
I know everything and that's why they fear me and that's why
they try to discredit me. And once again, guys, I'm schizophrenic
and I have a gun. I'm a very dangerous I hope if if Chimmu doesn't
get into the fake
cuz I think that is the best thing to bring up with Teccy Tone,
that he clearly faked schizophrenia for like
He's got to get into it, okay? One of my suspicions >> I
say months? I meant years. He faked schizophrenia for years.
>> of Teccy Tone was that after being accused of abuse
by his ex, he began to take on a personality as someone in the
far right in order to circumvent the audience he lost because
of his controversies. In other words, grifting. And you can definitely
see this change in his content as well. Some of my best friends
are trans
uh because they have not felt the same pain that certain content
creators have felt in this community. I mean, there's been racism,
racial slur towards Asian people, which is something that I do
not tolerate whatsoever. I do not tolerate hate speech whatsoever.
I do not tolerate anything derogatory towards any specific race,
gender, anything whatsoever. To be honest, I think I'm a pretty
progressive guy. People are trying to kill white people. They
absolutely are. I'm going to say something that a lot of people
don't like when I say this. Um I believe that white lives matter.
I do. No. What? What?
What? White lives? I've never heard that one before.
Oh my god. >> Tectone was complaining about the amount
of hate he got online and trying to attribute it to Pink. So,
when Pink's lawyer brought up his sudden political change of
heart, this is what Tectone had to say. So, if I can explain
on that, when all of these things came out, I lost pretty much
a lot She made me become a racist, okay? She accused me of being
a racist. So, I had to become a racist a racist.
Okay? It's He had no choice. He had to be racist after she called
him a racist. The racist are the only ones who accept racist,
okay? That's just facts. Everyone knows that. large chunk of
my audience and content creators kind of have to pivot what they're
doing to other topics once they lose access to a demographic.
So, originally, I never really covered anything political or
talking about, you know, white privilege. But, yeah, I would
say my content definitely had to find a new route on how to be
successful online. And so, unfortunately, I had to make a little
bit more extreme comments to be successful in the career that
I'm in now. Tectone, politically speaking, is a total fraud.
It's just further evidence that he's portraying a character to
benefit himself. It's become only clear from him calling himself
a progressive in earlier >> honest, I think I'm a pretty
progressive guy. Him admitting in open court that he is grifting.
Some of my best friends To be fair,
Tectone almost gooned himself into being trans. He probably was
a pretty progressive guy. Okay?
Not unlike Chud, he had himself into being attracted to like
the opposites. Okay? Once you become enough of like a total degenerate,
these kinds of things happen. He probably was actually at that
point a far more progressive person. are trans. At one point
in the trial, Pinky tells the story of a time she went to a mutual
friend and told her that Tectone was making her give him oral.
Once Tectone found out, he freaked out and made her call that
friend to find out what she knew and send text messages to Tectone.
This is big. We should watch this cuz
this was something new from the trial. for plausible deniability.
I told her that he would make me give him actions and she freaked
out. And I'm like, but it's all fine. It's not a big deal. And
I got scared because I didn't know if I could trust her. He then
the next day sat me in the office and sat me in a chair and he's
like, I'm going to get on the phone. I'm going to step inside
and out. And he stepped outside of the office and said, you're
going to tell me everything you told her in detail and I want
to know if you're lying and we're going to have her on the phone
back and forth and find out all the information. You're going
to text me that you want to perform this oral action on me or
else I'm not going to trust you. Shortly after all Dude,
I don't know how all of these like awful slop commentary channels
totally avoided that quote. They just totally dodged that quote,
right?
So, what they presented was, hey, why were you texting Tectone
like saying you want to suck his dick? Like right after this
fight.
then she comes out and she's like, well, obviously he told me
that I had to text him that in order to stay with him.
they had no rebuttal. They're just like, okay, just clearing
it up. So, basically Plant Dad, she described how their life
went and how she was basically like forced without consent
to give him like
right? And when she described these events to a friend, the friend
was horrified and said that's like sexual assault. Are you sure
you didn't say yes? And
and basically she freaked out cuz the friend was accusing Teck
Tone of sexual assault. She freaked out and told Teck Tone. Teck
Tone sat her down in a in the office chair and made her sit in
the office and call the friend and like re-litigate the whole
thing with him there. And then he said, "I'm never going to trust
you again unless you text me right now telling me you want to
suck my dick."
So she texted him. And then they used that text message as like
a reason why he's not a reliable witness in the
They're like, "Why did you text this to Teck Tone on like this
day?"
Which is just insane. And then she she comes up and then the
next time she goes to testify, she's like, "Oh yeah, the I he
made me do it."
And they didn't deny that. All this is said in the courtroom,
Pink's lawyer passes the witness, and they have absolutely nothing
to say. They don't try to question her on this history of events
whatsoever.
Teck Tone takes the stand after, and the story is never commented
on again. Shockingly, Teck Tone's team were the first to bring
up the original DM from Pink, who immediately starts to recount
a small portion of context in this incident. When she gives the
full testimony of this incident later, there is no pushback from
Teck Tone's lawyers, and they opt to not even bring it up once
Teck Tone takes the stand. Ask yourselves, why wouldn't they
push back on this? This is a huge claim by Pink, especially when
this text Teck Tone's team brought forward was really the only
substantial evidence that they even used in court. They are going
to push back on Pink with this? Teck Tone isn't even going to
say that it isn't true? Why? When Pink's allegations of SA went
public, a main defense Teck Tone employed multiple times on stream
and X was that SA against him because he had also been SA'd.
And to imply that I'm a rapist
>> after I myself
Dude, it just it goes hard. >> This is the same as the
Anisa thing.
It goes so hard every time. Every time I see it, it goes so hard.
How? have been I got to do it again. Thank you. >> after
I that I'm a after I myself have been raped twice
It's just a little bit to imply that I'm after I myself have
been
It's just a little bit crazy, isn't it? Do we know about the
second time, by the way? Or we only know about the one time?
Why is he panting like that? Cuz he's pretending that Hasan [__]
has destroyed him emotionally, okay?
We When we originally watched this, we realized that he was actually
raped three times. He just hadn't identified the Hasan comments
on his father as the third time yet, okay? It is shocking how
bad Tekton One might, I mean, one definitely would. I couldn't
possibly have done this. I was framed.
Yeah, that's a little manipulative,
I mean, it's
more than a little manipulative, okay? is on the stand. He says,
quote, "I'm not going to lie." five separate times throughout
the trial. It was pretty important to me because I am lazy. I'm
not going to lie. And I speed. I'm not going to lie. You know,
what if I get her pregnant? And also, you know, I'm not going
to lie. And I'm not going to lie. I was shortly after we broke
up interested in another girl. Pretty lazy guy in my life. I'm
not going to lie. Tekton several times goes on insane long tangents
where he throws in information not even being asked by his own
lawyer. For instance, his lawyer simply asked, "When you broke
up the first time?" Yes. It There was I want to clarify there
was three times. Once I believe Pink has forgotten about. There
was one where Pink wanted me
>> God, thank god Shamoo made this video, cuz this video
wasn't made and a lot of other videos don't go over this very
well. They don't go over like the Tekton part of the testimony
very well. And he was to- he's totally [__] insane
in his testimony. He's completely [__] insane, okay?
to have try to have and I swore to her that I would try and I
did and it just didn't work. I was too afraid of committing
It's not a thing to take lightly. I'm not a guy that sleeps around.
It's, you know, what if I get her pregnant? And also, you know,
I'm not going to lie. Uh Just admit you're gay.
Just admit you're gay.
Stop looking for women who literally take testosterone to be
fitness influencers and just admit you're gay.
It would be so easy, dude. The unfortunate reality is that I
did have a fear of vaginas. It's still hard for me to look at
vaginas. I'm a straight man, but something about them just scares
me. And so, you know, I you know, when I lost my virginity, I
had to even close my eyes just to kind of go through the motions.
Sorry. Am I rambling? What was the exact question? So, when you
broke up the first time, that was the question. So, when you
broke up the first time Yeah, there were three times to be clear
and like just so you know, I really just bro
That whole That's not even That's literally the transcript and
nobody covered that and laughed about that.
That's how crazy the coverage of this [__] was.
Okay? Nobody Nobody saw that
and was like, "Oh, this guy is totally out of his mind."
So, the first time that you broke up? Yes. Okay, sorry. >> Sorry,
we all laughed, but I'm saying like there aren't like daily commentary
channels that do this kind of stuff. It's just not there. He
admitted to being afraid of in response to when did you break
up? Yes.
Right. Okay. Yeah, there was the one time where she didn't get
Am I rambling? What was the exact question? So, the first time
that you broke up? Yes. You actually can't make it up. You can't
make this [__] up at all. >> Okay, sorry. Okay.
Yeah, there was the one time where she didn't get >> John?
Yes. >> Hold on. Yes. Imagine you're the judge. You are
presiding over this protection order case which includes multiple
incidents of alleged assault. And then out of nowhere, not even
prompted by the lawyer, the defendant goes off on a tirade about
how he is terrified of laying pipe. Shortly after a bizarre and
unprompted rant about Tectone's fear of female anatomy during
hearing for a protection order that includes SA, Tectone would
again go off on a tangent in which he presents himself as a philanthropist.
When did she move in? Oh, really quick. She would frequently
complain about her house. Yes, this is direct as in they should
have scripted this. This should almost be scripted
Like this is them laying out for the record the stuff they need
on the record, right? It should be uninterrupted, it should be
compelling. You are You know the exact questions you're going
to ask. Your lawyer should know exactly
what you're going to ask, okay?
Or sorry, you as the the defendant in this case, you should know
exactly what your lawyer is going to ask, he should know the
lawyer should know exactly what the responses are going to be.
There should be nothing no curveballs thrown
Miles and I had already flown in my other buddy Larro to stay
with me for free because he was struggling. And you know, I don't
like being alone, so I let him move in with me for free. And
then Pink said that her house kind of sucked, and she didn't
really have anything to do about it because she couldn't just
move out because she couldn't afford it. And I said, "Hey, anything
you need to make your life better, I'll do it. If you need money,
I got you." Because there was this funny time she was in her
house and she was very afraid because there was cockroaches.
And so I I I I came to my car and I speed. I'm not going to lie.
I I you know, I sped pretty bad. I went like 80 in like a 65
and I got pulled over that night and I told the officer, you
know, what the guy says, "Why are you speeding?" It's It's so
much better with the AI voices where you can hear
like it's good with my voice, sure, but it's so much better now
that I'm just sitting back and listening to how insane it is.
How how he just goes on these totally unrelated rants every time
he's asked a question. And I say, "Well, officer, it was for
a girl. This girl that I like, you know, she's got cockroaches."
And he says, "No problem, I get it." Lets me off. Gives me like
a warning and then I go over there and I pick her up and I bring
her back to the house and then I say, Why don't you just move
in? Everybody clapped. >> Tekton practically unprompted
goes off on a tirade. And then
everybody clapped.
I said I got to go see about a girl, okay? Just like have you
ever seen Goodwill Hunting? I said, "I got to go see about a
girl with cockroaches."
"Oh my god, go get that girl with the cockroaches, kid. Go get
her."
I ONE TIME I DIDN'T I DIDN'T chase the woman I loved and I regretted
it until THIS DAY. GO GET HER, KID. GO GET HER NOW. Great that
in my opinion just comes off as manipulative to the court. He
sort of presents himself as a hero. He let his buddy move in
because he was struggling and oh, by the way, it was totally
free. Pink couldn't afford anything and her house had cockroaches.
Tekton told Pink, "I'll do anything to make your life better.
Money? You got it. In fact, you can move in immediately." Later
under cross, Pink's lawyer also clarifies with Tekton that there
was only one cockroach, which he partially concedes to. And if
that's true, it just fleshes out the picture of how manipulative
he can be when presenting this stuff in open court and trying
to present Pink as destitute, basically. While things like this
may work on his YouTube audience, in the middle of a civil court
trial to go off on this long-winded rant only hurts him when
his lawyer simply asked, "When did she move in?" I [laughter]
cherish our marriage and you know that. A large portion of Pink's
by Tekton. And like just when you I hope some people see this
who only watch like the Think Before You Sleep video or a West
G video or a more Pegasus video and understand that they didn't
even make fun of this at all. This is like the funniest [__]
I've ever seen in my life and they didn't even cover this. That's
how [__] their job they are, okay? Tekton's lawyer
was to single in on her previous lawsuit with Tekton's ex-wife,
Fream, basically saying, "Well, you're calling him an abuser
now, but you weren't when you were trying to sue his ex-wife."
Which is already a pretty sticky situation for Tekton as in the
lawsuit itself, it alludes to his ex-wife on the precipice of
making abuse and essay allegations against him. She was going
to do something much worse, so bad it would have ruined all of
our lives. I'm not going to say what it was that she was doing,
but it was so horrific it would have ruined all of our >> The
allegations Freeman was going to make are alluded to in the lawsuit
with Pink. They have also been talked about in the background
for some time. The dispute between Freeman and Tectone relates
to a serious and false allegation against Tectone. During that
call, Tectone and Pink learned that Freeman had a Google Doc
and she was planning to release it to the public. >> Tectone
signed an NDA with his ex-wife directly after she was about to
come out with her allegations against him. This was one of my
main points in my first video and a thing I speculated over but
was unable to get answers about. This is also fleshed out in
the courtroom. Pink's lawyer asks, All right, and without going
into details, that NDA relates to a lawsuit between he and his
ex-wife post-divorce, right? I believe it was an agreement that
they made. He told me that he had sent her a cease and desist,
paid her $30,000,
and had her sign an NDA to not go public. And this was right
before you filed your lawsuit against her. Is that right? I believe
after he had her sign the NDA and paid her, I then we had our
spat and I sued her. Okay, and was that at his encouragement
to sue her? He encouraged a lot for me to sign an NDA and keep
all of it under wraps due to the allegations the ex-wife had.
He didn't want those to be public. Tectone later would be questioned
about this lawsuit between his ex-wife and ex-girlfriend. Pink's
lawyer states, And you >> No, I didn't interact on Twitter.
She must have seen some clip from me, gone and found my account,
blocked me. [__] up, man. >> Also, at the time
of the lawsuit, you wanted her to sign an NDA because you didn't
want all of your ex-wife's allegations public. Isn't this correct?
>> Can you repeat that, sorry? Sure. We talked about the
lawsuit, correct? >> Of course. And you tried to paint
it that you were not involved in it. In fact, wanted nothing
to do with it. Correct? I tried my hardest to not be a part of
it, but obviously when Pink was worried about it, I tried to
assist her. And in fact, what was the attorney's name that handled
the case? I'm actually not familiar. Aaron, you don't remember
Aaron? No, I'm not familiar with Aaron. You may be thinking,
why is Pink's lawyer asking Tek Tone about who represented Pink
against his ex-wife? Well, it's because Tek Tone, by his own
statements, was the one who got Pink's lawyer to sue his ex-wife.
In November of 2024, here is Tek Tone addressing Pink after her
allegations went public. How these things that have happened
in your own mind, you are now coming at me, and this isn't cute.
So, I am going to leave it at this. My Yes, it's AI Tek Tone.
Yep. >> My lawyer is going to be contacting your lawyer.
The same lawyer that I helped you get, the same lawyer that I
helped you get, because you were scared. I'm not [__]
around with this [__] I I My intentions were to kind
of just assist Pink. I mean, obviously, I think if I can toss
myself a bone in those situations, I'll do it. But, I mean, it's
mainly just about Pink, you know, being okay. One of Tek Tone's
claims was that he had all the receipts, and when all this came
out, he would be totally vindicated. Will you tweet out the
I I will at a certain point. I will at a certain point.
really Not only did he not tweet out the
he didn't take the proof to court.
He had a court case where that proof would have come in real
handy.
He didn't even take that proof to court. What are we to take
away from that, other than obviously no such proof ever existed?
Truly hope that you guys believe everything that is that I said.
If you didn't,
I'll provide proof later. So, shockingly, during the trial, after
a year of claiming he had all the receipts, he in actuality had
absolutely nothing. The tweets that I pulled were kind of just
like last second. I could probably dig more, but I haven't dug.
I maybe dug for like 15 minutes. Wait a minute. This has been
on file since August. You've known about this since at least
your video on November 21st, 2024. And you're telling this court
under oath that you only spent 15 minutes to dig up these just
for court today? Yes. Do you remember getting online and telling
all of your followers you had all the evidence back in November
of 2024 and you were ready to produce it all? Of course. We also
just get a straight-up
Wait, what does he say? Hold [clears throat] on.
Why do we pause there? What does he say in response? It's like,
yeah, he So, I assume she's going to ask, well, why isn't it
here?
What is What is the answer to that? from Tectone that he was
just a liar in the court transcript. Tectone explains very plainly
that he was let go from OTK over these allegations. However,
that wasn't what Tectone claimed at all at the time this event
happened. Okay, so where are those messages from 2020 that show
or from November 20th, 2020 that showed Sorry, November 20th,
2024 that showed that you immediately received notifications
of her post. Notifications are obvious. Oh, dude.
He doesn't She doesn't continue down that line.
Dude, if the lawyer had just said,
and so why have you not produced any of that evidence for court
here today?" She She should have asked that, man.
Cuz he would have answered. He would have He would have said
something I know it.
Oh, well. Little fumble there from Michelle Law. >> I left
OTK, why I resigned from OTK, why did not renew my contract with
OTK that expired on November 1st, 2024.
The original contract was 2 years with an additional option to
extend by an additional year, thusly completing my 3 years in
OTK. And the reason why I chose to not renew with OTK is because
it gave me a weakness, and I
I really don't like having weaknesses. Everyone was talking about
it, which is why it forced me to respond, as well as the owners
of my company decided to let me go as well because of the allegations.
So, people were ready to run with the ball of Look at that, another
streamer from this org is a piece of [__] And you
were let go? Instantly. So, Teck
Tone with his own testimony in court, is confirming he lied about
why he left OTK originally. Teck Tone from the start of the trial
tries to paint the picture of Pink Chyu being a totally unprompted
by his own lawyer, Teck Tone states, with me in my entire life.
Teck Tone claims during his time on the stand that his and Pink's
relationship was the most sexual one he had ever had, which I
just thought was bizarre considering they never had normal procreative
sex. >> What does that say about the rest of his life?
Yeah, because if I take it too serious, then everybody's going
to think that it's real. And when you're in a self-defensive
mode, you kind of got to say, you know, anything you can to save
face because when people are calling you a every day, Dude, it's
so crazy that he just says this. You just got to say anything
to save face, guy. You just got to lie to people. My audience
is totally
They're a bunch of rubes. I can tell them anything. They're complete
morons. You got to say whatever you need to say to keep your
audience there.
Wow. Thank you, Teck Tone. I mean, it's crazy when you say it
like that. I didn't really think you'd say it like that, but
I mean, you got to let it roll off the shoulder or make it a
joke. And so, the best way to defend yourself is to make the
other person basically a correct? I don't believe that's the
best way to do that. Well, that's what you've done. I mean, the
first thing you said when you testified today was that she was
the most forward woman that you have ever had in your life on
day one. I don't think calling someone forward is calling them
a Really? When you talked about it, you said you like long tongues
and she exposed her tongue. You thought that was appropriate
behavior? It was probably inappropriate. That's probably what
made it attractive, maybe though. I'm just not used to it. Do
you not see that you were painting her in a particular light
when you talk about these things in open court? I can only give
you an accurate representation of the truth. If it makes someone
appear a certain way, that's not really against or not really
my intention. One of the most important factors when a judge
making a judgement in these types of trials is the credibility
of testimony. A judge weighs demeanor, specificity, and plausibility.
So, imagine you're a judge presiding over this case for a protection
order that entails alleged essay. The first thing the defendant
does is say unprompted she wanted to immediately and then directly
after go on another unprompted rant about how terrified of he
is. I heard that [__] and I was like, "Damn, did
the schizophrenia get me?" One of the reasons this protection
order is so long Oh, yes. The schizophrenia
stuff. Okay, I want to see what Tech does or sorry, I want to
see what Shamoo says about those.
I'm I'm positive
that you can like make the claim basically flat out that he faked
his schizophrenia. He just totally faked it. It's been faked
the entire time.
Some people are like, "Oh, no, he's lying about it now to get
his guns back, but he's still schizophrenic." Nope, just obviously
fake from the beginning. is because for years now Tech has been
telling his audience in great detail and everyone around him
that he is a schizophrenic. It's called having schizophrenia.
I'm [__] schizophrenic. Wait, am I allowed to get
offended when people call people schizos because I have schizophrenia?
As a guy who actually is schizophrenic, as a guy who does have
mental illnesses, I'm schizophrenic. I'm really bad with horror
games, so if I have to quit, you guys need to understand why
that is. For example, I'm schizophrenic. I'm People normal human
beings aren't supposed to see things that aren't there. I have
lived a life where I've always felt like there were people trying
to kill me. I am also schizophrenic. Sometimes I can't tell if
I'm a schizophrenic or if I'm a shaman. Surprisingly, when asked
what he takes for this unfortunate The [__] shaman
thing is so annoying. I Every time I hear him talk about how
he's a
I get more annoyed. I get out I am actually more annoyed every
time. >> with just I just take multivitamins and fish oil,
so nothing. Kind of wanted to do a sleeve like that, but then
I realized I'm schizophrenic and it might freak me out. Might
make me think there was bugs in my skin. When Pink's lawyer asked
him why he isn't being treated for this very serious illness,
Tekking responds in only a way he can. I Well, I watched this
movie called A Beautiful Mind, and that guy was pretty Yes, it's
kind of goofy. Uh there's this movie called The Beautiful Mind,
and so I was like, "Man, his is messed up, and mine is nothing
compared to that." So, uh you know, I hear people like who like
like talk to people who aren't there, but I'm just like, "What's
that?" "Oh, it's gone." That's um you know, I've talked to spirits
due to my mental illness, but is it Here's the thing, And here's
the question I've always asked myself. Am I schizophrenic?
Or am I a shaman? And I obviously I'm schizophrenic. So, I mean,
her face starts like mutating. Brother, the the sheer damage
I would have inflicted on humankind if I listened to the voices
would be insane. You should peel off your skin, Tekking. You
should peel off your skin. Well, if that's what you think, that's
what's the truth. Though there were trials and tribulations for
Tekking Down throughout losing his civil case, just 9 days after
the trial, he would receive a miracle that cured his mind of
a decades-long battle with schizophrenia.
I have an announcement.
Um I went to a psychiatrist yesterday. And uh I'll I'll try to
provide some documentation of this at a later date whenever I
receive it. Uh guys, I'm not schizophrenic. Diagnosed with schizophrenia.
Voices, these lies to her head must leave. Now, if you're listening,
okay? If you know what Tekking Down's reasoning was for being
cured, if you know like how the psychiatrist cured him or said
he didn't really have it.
He was given like a a a reason for his
That only makes any sense for visual hallucinations. Makes zero
sense. Zero sense at all for auditory hallucinations. It does
not give you auditory hallucinations. It's going to It's going
to be in here, okay? Give me 2 seconds. I need to go to my door.
I'll be right back. >> schizophrenia. I have an announcement.
Um I went to a psychiatrist yesterday. And uh I'll I'll try to
provide some documentation this at a later date whenever I receive
it. Guys, I'm not schizophrenic. Diagnosed with schizophrenia.
Voices, these lies to her head must leave her in Jesus name.
Guys, I'm not schizophrenic. The psychiatrist believes the reason
why I see things that aren't there, mainly well, at
is due to the fact that I got stabbed in my left eye and my right
eye is normal. And so they believe that my eyeballs are causing
me to temporarily hallucinate things that aren't there because
they're not they're not signaling my brain properly. Okay, that's
great and all, but Well, hey Techy,
how does that explain the voices?
Wait, where where are those voices that tell you to peel your
face off, to peel your skin off? Where are those coming from,
man?
where are those voices coming from,
things that aren't there because they're not they're not signaling
my brain properly. Okay, that's great and all, but why do you
talk about hearing voices all the time then? I've talked to spirits
due to my mental illness. I'm schizophrenic.
I get really bad thoughts in my head. So I was going there, unironically,
and I'm trying not to get emotional. I thought there actually
might be something wrong with me. And so I was going >> to
actually try to get medicated. They said I do not require medication.
I I guess I am just a human with anxiety, unresolved childhood
trauma, and eyes that don't communicate too well with my brain.
Now, I personally have no idea where Tectone lies or
Reuben Reuben donated $3.
I hope he doesn't have pink eye.
Okay. Truth begins with any of this to be honest, because the
web is so massive at a certain point it's just a mad scramble.
But here's what we know. Tectone has stated that he plans to
appeal the court's decision of the protection order. Tectone
Tectone's going through some stuff right now. He He me know he's
going to be appealing. Dude, I love that we just call this guy
a spiritual advisor, all right?
It is embarrassing that Tactical Templar is the person who got
you to church,
Next hearing. You know, we we've seen the courts do things that
are just
that are not good. And what is the first thing Teccy can do to
help with his
Tactical Templar is one of the people reviewing this video tonight.
Tactical Templar, hopefully, if he's got big issues with these
videos or with this video, I guess. Hopefully, we'll get a chance
to talk to him, okay? Be good. Not be a self-admitted dangerous
schizophrenic with a gun. Once again, guys, I'm schizophrenic
and I have a gun. I'm a very dangerous man. Everyone has known
the person growing up that lies about this or that mental illness
they are afflicted with. I can't say one way or the other if
that's what Teccy has been but I can say his sudden cure of schizophrenia
only helps him with his appeal. If only Teccy would have listened
to the masters, his elders. Remember my dad told me I wasn't
schizophrenic, I just played too many damn video games. Shut
the [__] UP, OLD MAN. IRON
MIKE! WELL, I LOVE THE CAMARADERIE. Stop military I sent
my ops to the courtroom for Teccy and Pink And I have written
down notes for a 7-hour trial. I have 7 hours of It's so awesome
that Mis Gift is unveiling his diabolical plan to destroy Teccy.
And his dad is sitting here on the couch on his like phone, chilling
with his His dad's just sitting here in the
Just hanging out.
GET HIM, SON. GET HIM. >> It's so cool, dude. on Teccy
and what he did to Pink Chyu. Nice job, Teccy. You
true all-time generational hater moment online, Mis Gift, an
ex-member of OTK, sent people to the courtroom in Travis County,
Texas, >> for the entirety of Dude, this is like an all-time
stream. This stream is an all-timer, okay? This stream was so
good it I can't even put into words. It was just so so so good,
man. Tectone's trial with Pink Chyu. They even took video of
Tectone leaving the courtroom. Ready for this? There he is leaving
the courtroom today. The walk of shame as he lost the court case
to Pink Chyu.
He lost.
For 10 years, he can't own a firearm, weapon, or gun, and he
has to stay away from Pink Chyu. And has to pay all of her attorney
fees, which is hundreds of thousands of dollars. Besides having
agents in the courtroom, MissGif posted never-before-seen transactions
and texts of Tectone securing view bots for his various channels.
This is the bots that were bought. This is Tectone's account,
2004,
July 26th, quantity 1,000, quantity 750.
This is John Tectone messaging the person that was buying him
the bot saying, "Sad face, can you try that again? I'm stupid
and dumb." You just make an account, pay to the top right, and
add it to your account. "If you need help, let me know. It's
good for you to do it anyway since I won't be around. Let me
know if you need me to walk through it and I'll help you." Which
then they tried to help him with secure paying, okay? "Did you
get my bots?" So, Tectone definitely needing her to buy the bots.
"I can only do 750, but I sent you the link to everything." Sad
face. Dude, I it's crazy to me. How could you beat Tectone? He's
got like no skills. I don't I don't believe he graduated college.
He's never really had jobs. All he's ever done is like off and
play computer
How do you not know how to use the
like there's a level of incompetence going on here that is mind-boggling,
right? Like he literally can't make payments on the internet.
He's like too lazy or too stupid to make payments on the internet
for his own bots.
It's wild.
face, can you try again? I'm stupid and There's Tectone's picture
on August 24th paying a thousand dollars claiming it's the house
when it really was for bots. Why would Tectone pay a thousand
dollars for a house that he owns? If you're skeptical for whatever
insane reason, Tectone on his first stream back admitted to the
botting allegations. Hey bro, BRO, THERE WAS MOTHER going live
on stream saying, "Yeah, I view bot. Hold up, I got to send an
extra 2,000." Have I dabbled in it? You're goddamn right. I absolutely
tried it. Hey, all right, it is what it is. It is but I don't
do that [__] anymore, but it is what it is. The most
common thing I heard from people I spoke with about Tectone was
that he was a massive view botter. Tectone has made a lot of
money streaming and a lot of money from sponsors. Once Tectone
leaked a $35,000
payment he received on stream. Um is it a video? He's killed
it, man. Oh, I DID THAT. WHAT [screaming] IS THAT? ZERO I JUST
GOT
I THOUGHT SOMEBODY CALLED SO, THE THING IS IF YOU'RE VIEW BOTTING
AND YOU'RE getting tens or hundreds of thousands of dollars from
companies to shill their product to viewers that aren't real,
well, that's fraud. Is view botting bad? Um it really depends
on how you think about it. It it it it's kind of like lying to
sponsors as well. Do I want to feel bad that multi-million dollar
corporations are losing money? I don't really care about I don't
really care about companies losing money, man. I don't care.
I [__] it, man. I honestly am not sure if everyone
can just view bot and then steal from sponsors. I'm a tiny channel,
obviously, so I have no clue how prevalent this is, but it is
interesting Tectone openly admits to defrauding them. And guys,
I'm I'm going to keep this vague. I'm going to keep this vague.
Uh Honestly, he should just be auto banned from like a bunch
of
Like as soon as you're engaged This is This is like you work
at a company and you advertise
that you have embezzled money from that company. How the [__]
do you still work in that
What clown show industry would let you continue to work there.
Uh for a reason, okay? So, if you're confused, you're going to
stay confused. There were multiple incidents of SA spoken about
in the trial's transcript. I personally don't want to get into
details of all of them. However, I want to look at one incident
in particular because I believe the records and witness testimony
surrounding it absolutely sank Teek Tone and made me personally
truly believe that Teek Tone is guilty of what he has been accused
of. In late May, Pink Accu had just recently been to a plastic
surgeon to get lip filler done. The platforms don't benefit from
it. The platforms literally don't benefit from it. Finance does
this all the time. Yeah, but that's like the game with finance.
Sorry, finance are the best swindlers, okay? Anybody who's in
the finance, that's literally the game is how little conscience
do you have and how smart are you? How much can you get away
with it, okay? That's That's the
I don't think that's the streaming game. That's That is the streaming
game, but it's not
the swindling isn't of the platforms. The swindling is of the
people, okay? Yeah. Spruce Willis, you are literally not capable
of second-order thinking right now. What happens when all these
advertisers end up paying way way way way way more for advertising
that gets them no conversions? What do you think happens? Ding!
It's obvious that advertisers stop advertising.
>> at night. So, you just said it benefits the platforms.
It does not benefit the platforms for any length of time. Pink
Accu alleges Teek Tone asked her to perform an oral action on
him. She told Teek Tone that her lips were hurt because she had
just gotten this procedure done and told him she didn't want
to. It was so bad that she required medical treatment after the
fact, which is clearly stated on some of the court's paperwork.
Maybe you are a skeptic and want to say she made this up. Well,
don't take my word for it. Take Teek >> Right. You know
what you can't do to women who have lip filler? YOU CAN'T THEIR
MOUTH.
BECAUSE IT'LL RUPTURE THE [__] lip filler. SO, YOU
CAN'T EVEN GO HARD. AND YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOT MAKING THEIR own
money, so then you got to pay for another lip filler.
How do you know? Man, I wonder.
Jesus, bro. Like, bro, I'm telling you like these bimbos on the
internet, they are not worth a damn. By the way, fellas, just
letting you know, lip filler might look good,
terrible because when a woman has lip filler in, they can't suck
your hard, otherwise it might [__] up the filler.
>> clear he [__] up Pink Shoes' lip filler,
okay? Incredibly clear that he [__] it up. By the
way,
I know this is my one
kind of qualm with Shamoun and some other people is I while this
is proof that he ruptured her lip filler,
not proof that he non-consensually did so, okay? I'm I'm just
saying, okay? It's a little different. Now, I can divine Tectone's
like soul as a soul, and so I know that he did violate her consent,
but I'm just saying in a court of law, okay? It's not proof.
I know Tectone is right. I know Tectone has epigenetic memories
of right. I know all of these things, but it's not like it does
not re- meet the like legal standard of proof, okay? That's just
how it is. up their filler. So, it's like they'll look really
hot, but you can only go like 10% power on them. You have to
be care- Okay, so the thing The reason why it sucks
women who look like that is because I'm like a very like hard
Dude, this is the worst part of like This might be the worst
clip in retrospect after everything. I'm a hard
You know what I mean? Like I go very
Like very like very hard very fast.
Like it's fine to like start off slow, but then it becomes like
a battle,
right? Of who can [__] each other the hardest, right?
As you can see, Tekton quite clearly and disturbingly, with all
of the context, has quite often reflected on this event with
Pink, where after he allegedly forced her to perform an oral
action, she had to go to the hospital. You know, as a partner,
if a procedure has been done, it's on you to be caring and consoling,
not to take advantage of them when they are in pain after an
operation like this. I just think if your lips are hurting from
a surgery, and your doctor has told you not to perform any sexual
actions, what is most likely to have happened here? I So, this
is the This is the argument as you make it, right? Obviously,
she knew she just got lip filler. Obviously, I I think it's obvious
she told them, like, "Hey, we probably shouldn't be doing this."
This This is like the best way you can make the >> Tekton
himself talk about how forcefully he was, and just how bizarre
that is when your partner has just gotten a medical procedure
done. Now, after going over how Tekton performed in court, and
how he brought really nothing new to the table, you can see why
the judge found reasonable grounds to believe that an assault
happened here. This incident with the lip filler would also be
brought up during court.
Pink's lawyer asks, "Okay, isn't it true that you have posted
on social media that it's hot when girls have their lips done
with filler or jobs?" Yeah, of course. Okay, and in fact, you've
said on social media that you can't go too hard on them when
they first get their lip fillers done because it causes problems
with the filler, correct? I'm not familiar with that comment,
but perhaps I wouldn't say that I didn't say that. Okay, and
in fact, your exact statement on February 5th of 2025, so after
these allegations were made, is "These are so hot, but in practicality,
they are the worst thing to ever exist. So, lip fillers, they
do make your lips
the [__] But the problem is anybody who has lip fillers
cannot suck worth a damn. It
It sucks. It'll [__] up their lip fillers. It's just
not worth it. It's really not." >> Is that correct? Yeah,
I became very familiar with the flaws with lip filler. And Re-Resilient,
who did a great job running through the outline of the court
documents, also made a great point in regards to why Teek Ton
lost in court possibly. Presumably, the doctor Pink met with
after the lip filler incident testified over Zoom. >> February
23rd, Pink requested that a doctor testify via Zoom
on her behalf. I do really wonder what this doctor said. Cuz
I wonder if she This would be like actually really, really powerful
testimony if she said that I told him to stop and he wouldn't
stop. Like if she told the doctor something and the doctor wrote
it down was like, "Jesus Christ, man."
That would be really good. I do wonder if it was just hey, I
this happened because my boyfriend, you know, needed a [__]
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I eventually said okay or something.
I wonder if that's the impression the doctor had. I just I would
love to see the testimony itself. behalf. Not Teek Ton who saw
the court docs. So, whatever it was, it must have been compelling
enough, whatever she said was compelling enough for the protection
order to be granted. This is also backed up in the transcript
when the judge talks about generating a Zoom link for a witness.
They refer to the witness as a custodian of records, which is
someone in court that goes on record for the authenticity of
the records presented in court. So, Pink's doctor authenticated
the records of her injury to the court, which could have also
detailed the reason the injury was sustained in the first place.
And so, if you're the judge and you're trying to determine what
likely happened here, and you have someone claiming SA, they
have medical documentation and doctor testimony that they were
injured during this act. man being accused is talking about how
forceful he is in regards to doing this thing to someone recovering
from a medical procedure, what the [__] are you going
to think? It really is no wonder at all that Teek Ton lost when
you look at what both parties were bringing to the courtroom.
However, even with the protection order served, this still wouldn't
stop Teek Ton from communicating with third parties to mount
a defense for himself against his ex-girlfriend, which legally
speaking seems like a terrible mistake. Uh you can get laid anywhere
with some cash though. Viking dom, dude. 100% true. The Filipino
ladyboys in Manila. Right. And You're an expert. You're an expert.
Go east. I don't we just we just flawlessly moved into Legal
Mindset, Stark. Let's go. >> speaking seems like a terrible
mistake. >> Uh you can get laid anywhere with some cash
though. Viking gnome, dude. 100% true. The Filipino ladyboys
in Manila. >> Right. And You're an expert. You're an
Go east, gentlemen.
Legal Mindset or Andrew is a passport bro and YouTube lawyer
who lives in Asia. Legal Mindset laid a foundation for defending
Tekton publicly and Tekton, in my opinion, was also communicating
with and sending him things such as the transcript itself. How
did you get the transcripts? Legal Mindset magic, right? Things
just appear in Legal Mindset's inbox. And a confidential polygraph
test Tekton took. I've also got confidential polygraph results
that I obtained
uh that are very telling. Before Legal Mindset even had the transcripts,
he knew aspects of the case like how Tekton used a whiteboard
when he had a disagreement with Pink. And also, here's another
thing, too. Um and I think this does come up is the way that
people communicate with each other. So sometimes the way they
communicate it it doesn't seem normal. Uh it maybe they communicate
primarily by text or whatever. Maybe it's an IRL. Maybe they
do some other stuff. Uh I think with Tekton there might have
been a whiteboard involved at some point where they're explaining
stuff. Maybe that's just how they learn, right? Maybe that's
just how they intake information. That doesn't necessarily make
it derogatory or negative or >> Andrew at first tries to
find a way to talk around the fact that Tekton is incapable of
laying pipe by calling it a kink. Did his penis ever touch your
Never. So there was no penis to vagina that happened at all,
right?
It's a kink, right? Once again, kinks are kinks, right? Yeah,
that's definitely
uh
It was the most relationship I've had. Well, if it was only [__]
then I will just say that that's like
like like you know, maybe he just hasn't had a lot of relationships
like that. Anyways, I don't know. I don't want Why did I miss
that? How did I miss that? I don't remember that quote at all,
>> It was the most relationship I've had. Well, if it was
only jobs, then I will just say that that's like
>> Like, like, you know, maybe he just hasn't had a lot
of relationships like that. Anyways, I don't know. I don't want
to read too much into it, but yeah. Uh okay, I Then He's [__]
speechless.
He's literally speechless.
He doesn't know what to say. Later, he claims this entire protection
order with alleged SA is is simply because Tekton wouldn't lay
pipe, which is bizarre. Mr. Robertson, did you ever engage in
intercourse with Sure, first question is about that intercourse.
So, all of this is because
she didn't get and I'm going to use a technical term. This is
an industry technical term that I've heard from industry professionals.
She didn't get the beat up. Like my friend does, Sterling Cooper,
who used to work in the adult industry. Because she did not get
beat down. It appears that is what this is about. And the fact
that the lawyer led with that shows that that's the impression
she wants to give. This is the first question. I'm going to I'm
going to highlight you guys. The first question she asks When
in the transcript, Andrew is confronted with the clip of Tekton
confirming the lip filler incident when Pink had to go to the
hospital, instead of explaining to his audience why this is disastrous
for Tekton and his case, he just glosses over it and calls it
a mistake. So, after these allegations are made as lip fillers,
they do look make your lips look foolish. But, the problem is
anybody who has lip fillers cannot suck a worth a damn. It sucks
cuz if they suck it too hard, it'll [__] up the lip
fillers. Is that correct? So, he said that. By the way, okay,
this is pretty stupid, but saying lips look full is not a sin,
but, you know, you should just like not criticize
sucking abilities so much. I don't know. Anyways, the it probably
this was not a smart tweet, probably. But, whatever, let's continue.
Again, Tekton here is confirming the injury that Pink sustained
during the act. Legal Mindset basically thinks Pink is mentally
ill and runs all the stops is trying to paint this as a Johnny
Depp Amber I was going to say it. I do feel like I'm starting
to wonder if Shoe is like into feet or something. What are you
doing with this guy's feet on screen so much, Shoe? You like
90 seconds of run time with this guy's feet on screen. What the
[__] is happening? Heard situation.
Sh- Ap- Apparently, she's got a according to her own confession
some uh issues she's dealing with some trauma, uh maybe some
mental health stuff. Uh she's bipolar and BDD. Yeah, I mean,
that that'll do it right there. But, when Pig was worried about
something, it consumes her. Sounds like she has really bad depression,
too. Um And the important thing here is we are in a post-Depp
world. There's a lot of Me Too cases that end up absolutely destroying
men based on the laws in the West, but Depp versus Heard is one
that blew up, so I'm treating this like Depp versus Heard. But,
in a post-Depp world, we cannot
uh we cannot take
Me Too at its face. Andrew talks out of both sides of his mouth,
claiming that he is the only objective person who can cover this,
while also making it clear he is doing this as a third party
because Tech Tone is unable to. I'm going to be the only person
to cover this kind of objectively
uh from and that I that can cover it. That's the point here is
that Tech Tone cannot say these things, right? Uh and cannot
actually
move against her publicly, right? So, he can't defend himself.
So, a lot of people out there are saying Tech Tone, defend yourself.
He can't. He can't do anything. He can't say anything, right?
That's a big factor here as part I mean, I just feel like
to be honest, I just feel like he should have done that in court.
We don't have to get his spin where he's already said he has
to say things like whatever he can to defend himself online cuz
that's the job. We don't need the spin from him. I want to hear
what his defense was in court. And then we did hear it in court,
and it was abysmal. It was perhaps the worst testimony ever generated,
okay?
Everybody's like, dude, Tekton can't even like come online and
lie for himself anymore. >> Part of my analysis is that
Tekton can't fight back. So, uh this is why we want that he will
not cover this. So, this is why you need an objective go person
covering it and and he will not be covering this. He cannot talk
about this, guys. This is the point. The point is Tekton cannot
defend himself. And um to be honest with you guys, uh once again,
I if I'm going to disclose my
uh and I do have a bias here I like
And um I'm not going to pretend that I don't like Tekton and
I don't like the content he covers and that some of my bias is
towards his defense. The language of this protective order says
he cannot do anything to harass or annoy her. So, even releasing
documents
can be seen as harassing
or annoying. So, Tekton cannot release this document.
Now, LegalMindset
is not Tekton.
So, I can do I'm I can do what the [__] I want to
do. The other aspect to this is that LegalMindset refused to
redact any information such as names and addresses, which docs
Pink. The after events of the protection order ruling was a total
[__] show. Every document that was supposed to be
private detailing Pink's essay and home address were leaked originally
in Tekton's Discord. The person that posted it found a workaround
in the coding of the government site that allowed you to access
the files. I actually emailed Travis County because I was wondering
if this is Why do you so many like prolific
content creators? Love like consent violating con- What is the
deal?
I What is the deal?
Do you have a pet bird? I do not. I don't know why you asked
that. This is what happened and it turns out that it was. And
hours for me emailing the county, the file's accessibility was
shut down. Pink actually had to move because of all this. And
she actually responded to Legal Mindset on Twitter claiming this
is the quote lawyer Legal Mindset who posted unredacted documents
that were meant to be sealed live to thousands of people to dox
me putting my family in danger. Then pictured is a tweet of Andrew
hitting on Pink, which is sort of the more white trash aspect
to this I would say. You know, Legal Mindset is trying to sweep
it up and give an incredibly biased reading of a case where Tech
Tone is accused of SA, and then going on Twitter and hitting
on the alleged victim, and he's actually done it more than once.
When I pointed out to Legal Mindset it wasn't the transcript
but the court files that had
Uh I think the other tweet was old, wasn't it? I think this tweet
was like old. Like I think this tweet was before
like before he was had the documents or even knew about the protective
order case, I think. >> is accused of SA, and then going
on Twitter and hitting on the alleged victim, and he's actually
done it more than once. Poor chick attracts the worst kinds.
Ow.
I don't know about that.
I don't know if I'd say that.
I would say she is like uh nice. Listen, she posts pictures like
this. A lot of men on the internet find this very attractive,
okay? That's
that's just what it is.
When I pointed out to Legal Mindset it wasn't the transcript
but the court files that had leaked due to a bug Pink was upset
about, he both blocked me and hid my reply. Anyways, beyond being
a dishonest degenerate, I did feel there was an oddly poetic
moment during his coverage. When he breaks down crying about
his mental illness and then uses Pink's state of like of genuine
like um mental crisis to to weaponize against her? Yeah, that
was that was a good part of the stream. I did like that part
of the stream. >> to obviously work with Tech Tone to fight
against his ex-girlfriend who now had a 10-year protection order,
Legal Mindset very suddenly breaks down into tears. I'm going
to cry here, you know, because it's hard to do this it's hard
Okay, appreciate you guys. I got to lock in. I got to lock in.
I love you guys. So look at me. People are going to make fun
of me. Be like, look at Legal Mindset crying on stream. I don't
give a [__] So pretty simply what you have is Techtone
who just got a protection order by the courts working with and
sending things to YouTube lawyers to then release that information
and fight back against her in the public square. Oh, just wait
until you get to the Oh, you have to think before you sleep video
in here?
You do? Okay. Okay. >> Techtone and So Techtone went on
like a tour trying to go around to content creators and basically
tell them why he was innocent, give them more information why
he was innocent, and then like say, "Hey, there's a video coming."
Which he eventually That is eventually the think before you sleep
video, okay? Legal Mindset didn't always get along. In fact,
Techtone quite disliked Legal Mindset who used to refer to Techtone
as a 39 IQ buffoon. People like Techtone have lost reality with
like the real world and how things have to be in a contract.
Like, I mean, caveman caveman smash guy over there. 39 IQs in
the chat for Techtone. So, now Techtone, I guess, is going to
say something dumb. Wow. These people are just dumb. Like, are
they not think Does Shamoun not realize this before Techtone
got Legal Mindset into Mythic Talent and got him like sponsorship
deals and stuff? Come on, man.
Think about the reality of how these things work. >> This is
unfair. So, I don't want to keep you guys away too long. I think
we've seen enough of losing brain cells 39 IQ takes the night.
But, yeah, this is pretty bad. I I really I really don't give
a [__] about this Legal Mindset guy. I really don't.
Like, I mean, I I I could pretend that I do, but I just I really
just don't, man. Um and it I won't, man. I think Legal Mindset
is a very dangerous creator because a lot of people will take
what he says far too seriously. And he's really missed the mark
when he was talking about me. And I think that's very dangerous
when people hold your word to such high degree. Uh and then you
go farm and you just get some PR dunk points. I think that's
very dangerous. And obviously we got the VTuber uh Cinder. So,
if you don't But but I have just such a bitter taste in my mouth
ever since he attempted to [__] me uh over some Yeah.
I just uh yeah, I kind of just take everything
Ryan, that's what Techtone's thinking about, okay? Some dude's
covering me online. Oh, is he trying to [__] me?
He says with a grand assault and as Legal Mindset was being closing
in, he did a total 180 and began glazing Legal Mindset such a
degree it would make Thai ladyboys blush. American I highly recommend
everybody watching this video right now, go subscribe to Legal
Mindset and support the original channel as
I just like getting informed on everything and obviously pretty
soon I'm going to be getting very involved with the law and I
want to make sure that I am ready to dissect my enemies. Not
only was he glazing, but leading up to his legal issues, he was
also speaking with Mindset frequently. Which by the way, I've
been talking to Legal Mindset quite a lot. He's a very nice guy.
Believe and I'll have to ask Legal Mindset, Legal
Mindset, aka the man on Twitch. God, bro, look at him. He's hitting
on the dude. He's hitting on me, he keeps hitting on me, right?
It's a little bit uncomfortable, right? Just a few weeks later,
Pink filed her protection order against Techtone on August 21st.
Here's Techtone four days
I did not pre-watch this, by the way. That was uh odd that I
>> Legal Mindset is one of the greatest gifts to content
creation in the past three years. One of the best channels on
the entire platform and I stand by Dude. Okay.
This guy uh this guy is
gross. He'll just any if you're literally going to defend him
on anything, he will suck your dick unironically. Just happily.
Side note to you, Legal Mindset, you have now broken into my
five favorite content creators to watch. I was even watching
your YouTube live stream this morning. Amazing streamer, amazing
content creator, a brilliant mind of the legal space. I love
this Just one month after Pink got her protection order, Techtone
got Legal Mindset signed to Mythic Talent. That's So, of course,
I had joined the the talent agency, Mythic, and this put up was
put up on September 27th, so that's three days ago, which was
really awesome. Big thanks to TeckTone for helping me out. He
actually got me in contact and let me get in contact with the
leadership, the CEO, the COO. It was really awesome to meet them
and uh to talk about them. >> one of the things I'm not
even sure was very well known was that TeckTone was a creator
behind Mythic Talent. And then Mythic Talent was an organization
that I created with some peers from another company called AFK,
where they were actually, you know, not being too kind to their
employees. And so I took some of their employees and made our
own ad company to bring money to creators. You can send this
to um whoever the [__] wants to hear it. So I keep
on being told, and this is this is real, by the way.
I I've seen this comment so much. I keep on being told that Legal
Mindset is like incredibly biased and in my favor and will defend
me to the brink of death because I got him into Mythic Talent.
Me personally, it just seems like TeckTone courted Legal Mindset
leading up to his legal troubles. And once the protection order
was served, he used his connections in the industry to prop him
up and scratch his back, which would
I believe this is very similar to the Chud Logic allegations
that TeckTone goes to try to befriend befriend these people just
to get defended.
Okay? Now, I'm not going to call that like master manipulation
or anything cuz I don't want to have a whole bunch of spergs
in my DMs getting mad at me for saying it, okay? But it's a fairly
what do we call it? Um crude? It's it's it's sort of ham-fisted.
It's a ham-fisted ma- Yeah, I ham-fisted ma- manipulation,
would inevitably lead to Mindset's absurd defense of TeckTone
once the trial results came in. And getting Legal Mindset on
his side, hiring Mythic Talent, may in fact been a strategy.
I'm glad we have people like Sensitive Society and WestJet. Other
content creators who have collaborated and been on TeckTone's
podcast also covered this story, such as WestJet Sensitive Society.
I'm not going to sit here and lie to you guys and conceal my
bias. I want TeckTone to be innocent. I like the guy. I don't
want him to be a But at the same time, I'm not going to sit here
and carry water for TechTone and the girl with information I
don't have, calling her a liar and stuff like that. >> Because
I'm friends friends with TechTone, I guess it's time the elephant
in the room gets addressed. You guys know me, I like to keep
it a hundred with everyone. And of course, it's no
I don't even I'm I'm not even going to lie. I'm not going to
lie. I'm not going to lie. I'm not Guys, I'm not going to lie.
Hey, I'm not going to lie. that I like TechTone
He's been nothing but kind to me. A few months ago, he invited
me onto his podcast So, they state their biases in the video.
However, for large portions of both of their videos, simply had
LegalMindset giving the most absurd takes on the case. They're
almost trying to paint him in a way, if you know what I mean.
>> never actually engaged in traditional intercourse. It
was only he received There was never any reciprocation. So, they're
literally making a case that that because he didn't have sex
with
this is abuse.
Right? So, I I just want to That's and not at all what the case
is. >> make it clear here that there's an argument here.
Love this Andrew guy. Really, the problem is they didn't Now,
thankfully, YouTube lawyer made a video about this a day ago
explaining everything. He approaches very innocently after he
was betrayed in a relationship which Fream cheated on him. In
fact, all the communications I reviewed show TechTone as a reasonable,
kind guy. >> Don't say. He says, "I will never understand
how much this must hurt you, but proud of you fighting through
it." And this is not the language I would see of an abusive partner,
someone who's hurting, or someone who's out there to get somebody,
but someone who really genuinely wants to help. And it seems
like this may be a There's case of what you call buyer's remorse.
What a nice
Here's a tweet. Guess Guys, guess how much it means to tweet
nice things at somebody. Guess how much that means in terms of
like your effort, what they actually get out of it. A zero, okay?
Zero. It means nothing. Means literally nothing. remorse in dating
uh where you go back and you say, "Okay, well, now that I'm out
of this now that I'm out of this this is a situation where it
was buyer's remorse. I regret things I did or I regret stuff
I did even though it was consensual at the time." Now, I'm pretty
sure those thousands of dollars she spent to make sure she didn't
have to blow them, those she does not have buyer's remorse on
those, okay? Best
Best $4,000 for 30 days of peace she's ever spent. >> And unfortunately,
as I got to report to you guys, the US system legal system weaponizes
it. So, it allows people to go back Oh, very lucky charging Jim.
Nobody's ever hit someone that they've said they love. That's
never happened
I love you. Oh, wait. That means I Oh,
I can never hit you again. I said it. It's It's a spell. back
regret things I don't know why I I think never mind. I'm continuing.
I don't know why No, I have to I don't know why I was like, "Oh,
I'm I imagine myself as somebody hitting someone and then it's
like, 'I love you.'" And then I Oh, no. I can't hit you anymore.
I brain go there. just go make claims in the future when all
of this should be dealt with privately.
My problem with those of these videos is that if you're going
to talk about this case, then people should actually know some
of the damning things within it. If you aren't talking about
how Pink while recovering from an operation was injured, that
there is medical documentation to back it up, and that Tekton
himself has openly stated that this event happened, and you just
have Legal Mindset on screen talking about how the problem actually
is that Pink wasn't getting then that's sweeping. I think it
largely helps Tekton. Obviously sweeping, yes. >> from
people that have collaborated with them. It also seems like at
least WestJet had some idea that Tekton was just working with
Legal Mindset. >> a great point, Jim, really. Yes. It is
very important if somebody if you love somebody to correct their
bad behavior, okay? These are just corrections.
It's not It's not a punch. It's a correction, okay?
Come on. I generally don't know how effective polygraphs are,
but it is interesting how Legal Mindset even got this confidential
file in the first place. Sensitive Society would actually issue
an apology for his video. >> his opinion, the only people
that I care about is my audience. And if you feel let down by
my video on Techtone, I do apologize for that. It a 1000% falls
on me. I think I should have done a better job covering the situation.
Maybe not be as biased. And shortly after would take down both
his apology and the original Techtone protection order video
he made. They call him a generational ri Yes. When you have people
that are spreading
uh you know at least from his perspective, the court case is
not finished. And so I do know more about it than the public.
And I and also I remain to be Techtone's friend and I support
Techtone. You can take that for what you will. So as somebody
who knows more about this than the public, I think that when
he comes back all of this is going to make a lot more sense.
I'll certainly say that. So don't worry about it guys. Techtone
will be back. It's not going to be a big deal. Everything's totally
fine. Asmongold supported Techtone and frequently alluded to
Techtone's innocence and knowing things the public didn't. However,
once Techtone lost his case, this was his reaction. Streaming
is just it's so toxic, man. Techtone's the civil [laughter] case.
Based on
You're going to it's going to all be better. You're going to
really get it once he comes back, guys. He loses. Streaming is
just so toxic, man.
>> Bro, that's a same level of switch up is um I think
if I think if Israel bombs Iran, we should just totally leave
the Middle East. We should totally pull away all support. And
then 6 months later just be like, get him.
Should have [__] around. Now you're going to find
out.
What do you What do you say? That those school girls? Collateral
damage. >> on a lawsuit that I'm in right now, I don't
want to make any comments on it just for the sole reason of because
of that lawsuit. If it wasn't for that, I would have talked about
it a lot. So Asmongold has this lawsuit with Mizkif. However,
many people covered the trial's fallout and it really doesn't
prohibit him from talking about Techtone's case. There's no reason
to include Mizkif Kiff >> Or maybe maybe all of my friends
are just, you know, problem boys, right? Cuz I have tons of friends
that have like felonies and they've been in jail and everything
and so The [__] is this guy saying? What? Does that
not
That paints you in a bad light, man. I don't know what the [__]
you're talking about. Lacari, I think this was before the Lacari
stuff. He He doesn't even know about the Lacari stuff yet. You
know, I guess for me
you know, it's not that big of a surprise. I don't really care
or want to have anything to do with other people's
I just don't give a [__] about it. Like I don't I
don't want to talk about it, explain it. Basically, Asmongold
just took the cop out. Techtone's lawsuit has nothing to do with
Miss Kiff whatsoever and in reality, it's just a bad look for
him as someone who has been defending Techtone leading up to
this point where he is then found civilly liable for SA.
uh somebody in your chat said don't call her a No, she's What
do you mean she's a Techtone Techtone?
You dated a [__] It Uh, this guy is a an actual Nux
Taku, total total I just I I feel it, man. I can feel it. Nux
Taku is another creator who after the court's decision defended
Techtone, obfuscated aspects of the case, and attacked Pink or
Techtone. However, I just wanted to illustrate how these people
work and how these absurd defenses go both ways. You scratch
my grooming back, I'll scratch your back. >> Looked like
Nux Taku completely obliterated all of the allegations that were
thrown his way in a matter of 5
Uh, fun fact, Habanero Gilla makes it into most Shamoo videos.
I think I've never watched a Shamoo video that Habanero Gilla
is not in,
You love this guy. Uh, so that was always really fun. And then
the amount of people were like, "Ah, you need to denounce Nux.
You need to denounce Nux." I'm I'm good, bro. I love Nux. It's
also worth noting this isn't the same as someone just ignoring
a controversy, let's say. Some of these people are actually trying
to obfuscate and to dishonestly represent aspects of these stories
in an attempt to benefit themselves and the person they are subverting
for. Think before you sleep, I would say had the most insane
video on the topic where every subject is missing a ton of context
and it's all in service of attempting to help TechTone. The first
2 minutes he just talked [__] about Pink and calls
her a catfish. >> this is an insane amount of catfishing.
I'm not even looking at the same person when I compare a live
stream to a photo of her. Oh, my god.
A woman on OnlyFans
Photoshopped a picture. What? No.
No. He does bring up the lip filler incident, but pretends there
isn't medical documentation or TechTone talking about the incident
on his stream several times. >> Anyway, Pink Sheu said
that she had just gotten lip filler and TechTone had By the way,
her most popular content is is like video content. I think that's
a way harder to filter, right? Like she does like group video
content
I think I whatever. I don't need to sweep for >> into oral
which had ruined the lip filler. Geez, another plastic surgery
related incident. Do all of her allegations have some sort of
plastic surgery involved? Now, is there any corroborating evidence
that this happened? Not really. >> You know what you can't
do to women who have lip filler? YOU CAN'T THEIR MOUTH BECAUSE
IT'LL RUPTURE THE LIP FILLER. YOU KNOW, it's very delicate like
with the lip injections, you can't [__] them as hard
as you want to because then it'll [__] up their filler.
So, it's like they'll look really hot, but you Jesus. Eesh.
I believe that is a cow and then there's like milk splashing
in the background. So cool, man. You can only go like 10% power
on them. I'm like a very like hard
You know what I mean? Like I go very hard. TBYAS throughout the
video explains that he believes the protection order is actually
a grand conspiracy by Hasan [__] and his lackeys.
Now, this whole situation was a coordinated effort from multiple
streamers to Hasan's back. >> ruin his career. Hasan [__]
has this ongoing war with Asmongold, probably because he's mad
that Asmon is more famous than him. Hasan likes to sit back and
have his little lackeys do all the dirty work for him. This is
a famous tactic of his and he primarily works by not directly
saying that he has certain values, but he will signal boost all
the people who have the values that he wants to promote by watching
their content on his stream. That being said, Tectone is friends
with Asmongold. You can't Can we apply that lens to Asmongold,
Tectone?
They sure do like each other's content, do they? What kind of
values are they trying to promote, guys? What do you think? Well,
Hassan wants to attack Asmongold in any way that he can. So,
I think his lackeys came up with a plot to destroy Tectone. They
do this a lot. So, what are we trying to do here? Well, with
absolutely no evidence, TBYS wants to impress upon his viewers
that if you think Tectone think again, because this is actually
a plot from Hasan [__] who's pulling the strings
in the background. It's so absurd to me that anyone would try
to use Hasan [__] as a shield from being found liable
in civil court for SA, someone who has literally nothing to do
with this protection order between these two people. And really,
it should be an insult to the intelligence of someone's fans
to even try to push something like this, but here we are. Tectone
behind the scenes was sending streamers this video and told them
it had been in the works for a long time. And I know there might
be some people thinking, "Oh my gosh, does uh does Teckles even
want you to watch this?"
Yes, he asked me to watch this. So, yes. He He's He's He's told
me this one has been in the works for a while. >> There
it is. So, yeah. That's one of the reasons why we're going to
be watching. So, let's think about this. After receiving a 10-year
protection order where the judge found reasonable grounds that
Tectone had committed stalking and SA, he is now sending hit
pieces against his ex-girlfriend to other streamers where they
are pretty openly doxxing her and not redacting any info. This
is true in TBYS and Legal Mindset's case. It is a violation of
the protective order to use a third party to harass a protected
person. So, if Tectone is facilitating this with other creators,
he could be in some serious trouble before this is all said and
done. But, in both TBYS and Legal Mindset's case, I personally
believe there is just more for them to gain in defending Tectone
and trying to obfuscate certain aspects of the case we talked
about today. Tectone co-created Mythic Talent. He has many different
connections in the space and remains friends with creators like
Asmongold.
Being closer to those networks is obviously beneficial for people
operating in that ecosystem. This case is not your typical run-of-the-mill
accusations online case. We have medical records proving there
were injury sustained during the alleged act with numerous references
to the incident by the accused. This makes it all the more depraved
to me that people are so willing to just obfuscate details of
her case in order to get ahead online. It's about as slimy as
it gets, really. Tectone, of course, utilizing these people to
attack his ex-girlfriend, who now has a protection order, really
goes to show the pattern of behavior and only reinforces some
of the reasons the protection order was granted in the first
place. Both Tectone's ex-wife and ex-girlfriend have accused
him of SA. In my first video, I laid out a timeline and multiple
examples of Tectone lying to show why my viewers should be more
open-minded about what may have happened with his partners. Now,
we also have medical records documenting bodily harm and Tectone
himself admitting on camera that the injury occurred during a
sexual act. That kind of documented injury can function as an
aggravating factor and strengthen a finding of liability.
There are only so many occurrences that can happen before giving
someone the benefit of the doubt becomes untenable. So, it's
not just my personal opinion that Tectone did these things. But,
given the repeating pattern with his ex-wife and ex-girlfriend,
I fully expect this type of behavior from him to continue. Given
how Tectone has handled losing his case and coordinating with
other creators to attack Pink using third parties, it would not
surprise me in the slightest if there is further and greater
fallout from all this.
We'll just have to wait and see what the future holds.
Thanks for watching. Peace.
This guy just thanked the Anons. Thank you, Anons. Wow. Already?
Okay, it's fine. Wow, what a video. Hey guys, please hit like
on the video as it helps the channel and the algorithm. If you
want to support more content like this, you can do so at patreon.com/sham
41. If you have cash app, you can donate at dollar sign sham
41. Also, channel memberships and super chats are enabled.
>> I will Oh, what the [__] I just clicked
>> Iran never I will Oh, that just went over to the video.
Okay, I'm going to link the video in the chat so that you guys
can like it so you can That's not it. Me. Come on, man. Come
on, man. >> It's been 8 months. It's That's literally my
blastoff tweet. Get that [__] out of here. Here's
the video. Like the video. Watch the video. Okay, don't just
open it and close the video
Literally watch the video on your own time later. Subscribe to
Shamoo. Okay?
All right?
Important. Important you support this guy and the great work
he is doing.